with which europe is increasingly under
pressure from many events
coming to europe from outside the issues of
internal and external security and
terrorism consumers of
globalization ideas in the usa and
in russia for europe to
split up again
the consequences threaten to be europe
has to do something
lisbon is the constitution of the
european union
and like this constitution you can do a
lot more politics when it is
fully exhausted than that
has been done for so far
we have to create more transparency we
have to have majority decisions de
facto we have  have to move much closer together in the area of
defense social policy
and if I
save a lot of money
the mission european union give
years ago euros for distributed Kraus with a double these early results from russia ran more soldiers
and some states of america
are not weak either  h because everyone
does their own business there are 38
different transport from its
low europeanize waste
of money and you send
[music]
if about the euro group will the euro
is the currency of the european union
that will be responsible institutions
the council of ministers take the commission
and the european parliament and then
there's another authority for 19 countries
founded again then that's
a kind of split in the european union
that's why you should make it, for example, in
this person that he
'll get the head of the euro group on the cold war
brilliant and they too  way of
putting things together not
divergent
[music]